let's suppose I'm at a networking event
or I get invited to a write festival and
it's a mixer so someone says hey so you
write may I see your work and I know
it's probably not ready what's the best
way to let them know that we're I'm not
hurting their feelings really sure it's
a great question I would say that oh
that's fantastic
can I get your card I'm I'm doing
revisions and I'd love to send it to you
when it's ready oh so just like I drop
you and you know can I drop you an email
as a reminder when it's ready sure
that'd be great oh great so you're not
waiting a year for the revision you're
keeping them in your mind or in their
mind sorry you're saying hi I met you
you know and thank you sadly and you
know what it could be a year if that's
if that's really what it takes to me
it's ready when it's ready so Andy I met
you a year ago at the at Sundance and I
mentioned a sci-fi one-hour trauma that
I have and I finally have it ready and
it's been vetted and actually I don't
even know if I would go into all that
detail but it said I mean and here's the
brief premise the very very briefly
executives don't want a whole big
description because they also can be
liable they don't want to hear ideas in
too much detail because they're not
allowed to accept them for legal reasons
but if it's someone that you have met
and just to give them a refresher this
is the sci-fi one-hour pilot about an
alien who comes to earth can I send it
you and they'll either respond and say
great or they might say no that also
there's another subject which is
submission release forms because a lot
of executives and agents will not take
material without a submission release
form unless it's being if it's this is
if it's not being submitted by an agent
or manager interesting yeah I wonder if
people really understand that when
people see and I've seen on it on
people's Twitter BIOS do I do not take
you know and I see it all the time
so and I for a newbie I do think they
realized the implications and how it's a
turn-off to when someone says no like
that there's reasons why right it's not
because they are they they don't think
your idea is good it's because they're
protecting them so right so then there
are ways around to try and bypass that
and yeah that would probably fall under
a whole conversation there's a
networking and Submission policies
whoops but for someone to respect that
when they see that someone says we do
not take line positions okay yep well a
good counter can be okay I'd be happy to
sign a submission release form and as I
say that my you know disclaimer is that
as I'm saying this I am not an
entertainment attorney Sean so whoever
you may be listening if you get a
submission release form you I advise you
to show it to an entertainment attorney
and it is up to you to decide whether to
sign it or not but that is a way around
that legality of them not wanting to
accept it at all
you